僕はピンストが強かった
ジェンダー問題は関わってはいけないもん
だと思ってた
何も悪いことをした覚えはないのにどう
やろうと子は悪いらしい
まんだ僕たちが
的みたいな
怖い
そんなせ民主とに関わりたくない
ジェンダー問題にも関わりたくない
ジェンダー問題は関わっちゃいけないもん
だと思ってた
自分には関係ないと言い聞かせた
でもの僕はジェンダー問題に取り組む
アクティビスです
僕自身も face です
男だけど
フェミニストです
ではどうしてぼくが行動を起こすように
なったのか
うわシンプルに身近に行動後せる場所が
あったから
知識なんてなかったけど仲間になって
くれる人とそこに問題があるとわかる問題
意識があった
ではどうしてぼくが問題意識を持つように
なったのか
それは幼少期の記憶にさかのぼります
僕が幼稚園生だった頃
いつものように母親とスーパーに行き
買い物を済ますと僕はパワーが持っていた
レジ袋を見てこう言いました
ボケが運べよと
当時から進退的に男性が強いということを
知っていたようです
そしてレジ袋を受け取った僕だったんです
がそれがものすごく重かったっ
男の僕にはとても運べなかったッ
あれっ
何かおかしいぞ
男の僕の方が強いはずなのにどうして
お母さんはこれを平気な顔して持ってるん
だ
よく考えたらお母さんはこれをほぼ毎日
やっているではないか
よく周りを見たらスーパーにいる大半の人
が女性ではないか
この瞬間僕の頭の中にあった男性が強くて
女性が弱い気で洗脳が解けました
そして女性も強いんだ
という風に信じるようになりました
ここまではとある少年の話です
しかしストーリーは続きます
女性も強いんだと信じて育った僕だったん
ですがどうや社会には僕と違う価値観が
あるぞということに気づいたのです
男女で扱いが変わることを知ったのです
これはものすごく衝撃的だった
女性も強いんだ不思議して育った僕にとっ
て女性が男性と違う扱いを受けていること
にモヤっとしたのです
今のを覚えているのは僕が中学校で野球部
に入ったときのこと
女子は中学からは野球部に入っちゃダメ
女性だからダメなんだ
性別で区別が起こるんだ
もやってしたっ
これはとても個人的なもので日常のワン
シーンを切り取ったものですがここからで
もジェンダー問題を垣間見ることができ
ます
スポーツにおける男女格差
2021年にフォーブスによって発表され
た世界の年収トップ約アスリート
100人中たった2人だけが女性でした
日本でも同様の傾向があります
またスポーツ界以外でも男性の方が収入が
高いのが実情です
4のジェンダーギャップ指数は156カ国
中120位
特に政治と経済の分野での格差が世界に
比べて大きいのです
ここまでの話は既に多くの方がご存知で
あろうかと思います
ここでくれることは男性に特権があると
いうこと
特権とは社会における優位性のことをいい
ます
2,800万円
この数字が何だかわかりますか
男女の賃金格差
いえ違います
これは男性の特権のでなんです
アメリカの it 業界を基に算出された
数字ではあるんですが
男性と女性が同じ仕事をした際に出てくる
男女の賃金格差のみならずウソン女性が
男性と同じ昇進の機会を得るのに必要な
学費の差などの総額です
この研究で女性が男性と同じ昇進の機会を
得るためにはより高学歴な大学により長い
時間通い続き支え続けなければならないと
いうことが明らかになりました
日本でも同様の傾向があります
つまり
男性は男性であるという理由だけで人生で
大きく得をするのです
これまでの話を聞いていると男性は
あたかもすべてが木駅人生を楽に行きただ
甘い汁を吸っているだけのように思えるか
もしれません
しかし裏には別の問題が存在します
次の数字について考えてみてください
男性は全体の80%
前は元年度に犯罪を犯した人における男性
の割合です
男性は圧倒的に犯罪を犯しやすい傾向に
あるのです
犯罪は社会からの逸脱行為として考える
ことができにしばし気を付けさんという
心理カウンセラーの方によると男性がここ
まで多くの犯罪犯す背景には男性が社会的
にストレスを溜め込みやすいからという
指摘があります
男性は社会の中でストレスを感じているの
です
次の数字についても考えてみてください
男性は女性の2倍
これは連はに年度に自殺をした人における
男女比です
決勝のデータによると自殺の要因は大きく
五つ
学校健康
経済圏6そして男女問題に分けられるそう
です
これらの理由中で男性の自殺が圧倒的に
多い理由が2つありました
それは勤務問題と経済問題
男性を犯罪者と発射するストレスと男性を
自殺に悪夢勤務問題と経済問題
どうして男性も社会の中でここまで苦しま
なくてはならないんでしょうか
それは社会から男性に押し付けられる
イメージがあるからです
ではそのイメージとはどのようなものこと
を言うのか
恋愛における場面を考えてみましょう
告白やプロポーズ
男女の場合だとどちらが積極的にやる
イメージ館
デートでエスコートして女性にご飯を
おごってあげることがいい男なのか
たくましく香月てあげられたか裏を持つ
ことが男らしいのか
家族についても考えてみましょう
一家の大黒柱って誰なんですか
結婚したら誰の名字を使うんですか
男性は家族のために身を粉にして働くなく
てはならないんですか
仕事についても考えてみましょう
そもそも男性って
食を手に入れなければならないんですか
収入が高ければ高いほどいい男なんですか
男性は仕事第一にしなければならないん
でしょうか
男性には大きな責任やストレスが
のしかかります
これは男性を犯罪や自殺に追い込むこと
です
実は職場などにおけるストレスから日本は
世界で唯一
男性の交付とが女性の幸福度よりも低いな
のです
このようなイメーションしつけは幼少期
からも始まっています
男のかんだから強くありなさい弱音を吐く
な泣くなん少年漫画少女漫画と分けられ
男の子用のおもちゃを与えダメおままごと
で男性としてどのようにするマーカーを
勉強していく
このように人生のさまざまな場面多くの
ステージで社会から男性のイメージの
押し付けというものが行われています
これらのイメージの中で男性を苦しめる
ものを有害な男性ぞ
特積マスク便器と言います
ぜひ男性の皆さんにはこれらのイメージに
ついて考えていただきたい
どのイメージが僕たち男性を苦しめる者な
のか
ゆがー男性像に明確な答えはありません
どうぞご自身でお考えになってください
ただ一つだけ言えることはこれらの
イメージによっていきづらいと感じる男性
が多いということ
これまで男性の順だ問題はあまり
スポットライトが当たって来ませんでした
ですのでこれを機に男性のみなさんには
男性のジェンダー問題について考えて
いただきたい
さてここまで男性にを半焼してきましたが
これらの男性問題は他のジェンダーには
関係ないでしょうか
いえそんなことはありません多くの
ジェンダー問題は表裏一体です
男性が活躍する労働の場に保管ジェンダー
は社会進出できていません
また女性が社会的に役割を果たす家事や
育児に男性が介入することを基本的にはし
ません
むしろそうすると珍しいという値するほど
です
男性が既存の社会的役割から出してなけれ
ば
女性も同様に今の社会的役割に縛られた
ままになってしまうでしょう
このように男性のジェンダー問題は保管
ジェンダーにも大きく関係しているのです
さてここまで男性問題についてお話をして
きました
コカはどうして僕がフェミニストになった
のか
僕をフェミニストに変えた気づきについて
お話ししたいと思います
ここが一つお話をさせてください
これはとある友人の女性から聞いた話です
ある日村女性がバイト先でミスをして
しまった
その時すごん店長さんは彼女を叱らなかっ
たそうです
しかし子です男性のアルバイトが同様の
ミスをした際
そこの店長さんは彼のことをものすごく
しかった
何かもやっとするものはありませんでした
か
きっと多くの方が共感できたはずです
男性からしてみれば何か女性って優遇され
ているよねとか
女性化してみるとどこか子供扱いをされた
ように感じる方も多いかと思います
このような話よくあることだと思います
女性は運転が下手運動ができない女性なん
だからできなくても大丈夫
ここで次の質問について考えてみて
ください
女性ができないならば誰ができるのか
男性ですね
男性は社会の中でできなければいけないと
いう期待をかけられるだから生き残です
男子なんだからこれくらいできて当たり前
でしょできないなんて男っぽくないメメ子
このように社会の中で男性はさまざまな
ことができると期待されているのです
でもそんな完璧な人っていませんよね
みんなどっかしら苦手なものがあります
そこ
社会からの期待に応えられなかった部分で
生きづらさを感じどう
ではどうすれば僕たち男性がこの行き坐せ
か解放されるのか
考えてみてください
答えはいたってシンプルです
期待する基準が男性かどうかじゃなくなれ
ばいい
ジェンダー関係なくそれができる人がやれ
そうすれば僕たち男性からすればできない
ことを期待される必要がないし
社会にとってみても本当にそれに長けて
いる人が活躍する社会
理想的じゃないですか
今は社会主に労働の場に男性しかいない
から男性に勝手な期待がかかるのです
今男性は自ら自分たちの首を絞めているの
です
だからこの役させから解放されるためには
男社会から脱却しないといけない
男社会から脱却のために他のジェンダーを
応援する
僕たち男性が行きやすくなるために女性の
社会進出を応援したいから僕はフェミース
なんです
なんて言うと思いましたか
現実は
そんなに甘くない
今では男性からしてみると仕事を奪われる
と不安になる方も多いかと思います
先ほどの理想の社会に共感は出来ても9日
それに向かおうと思えない人が多いのでは
ないでしょうか
また女性も女性で女らしさにとらわれて
いる
要するに女性も社会の中で期待されている
ことがあるんですよ
出産妻は仕事を辞めないといけない家事
育児をしないといけない
それなのに労働も男性と同じようにし
なければならないと考えるとさすがに負担
が多すぎますよ
イクメンが増えないのもこの理由
ここを改善しないといけない
男性の現場の問題点は
今男性が活躍できる場が主に労働の場しか
ないということ
だから仕事を失うことをものすごくを
添える
は最悪の場合自殺や犯罪に追い込まれる
ことです
そんなは男性が職場以外でも活躍できる
ようになればいい
男性が職場に縛らず職場か家庭かどちらか
を自由に選べるようになればいいのです
逆に女性の現状の問題点は女性が今家庭に
縛られていて社会進出をしようとすると
職場とか体の両方での活躍が求めだね負担
が増えてしまうということ
その幅
女性が家庭に縛らずにヒョクばか家庭か
どちらかを自由に選べるようになればいい
のです
音男性と女性どちらも同じ結論に至りまし
たね
現状の場所に縛られずに職場か家庭か
どちらかを自由に選べるようになればいい
これこそがまさに
フェミニズムが求めるものです
ジェンダーの壁を超えて誰もが同じ権利や
選択肢を持つということ
血腫男性嫌悪でもないし男性から何かを
奪おうとするもんでもない
ただみんなで同じものを持とうという考え
方
だんだん僕はフェミスだよ理由が分かって
きたと思います
これの障害などが男らしさや女らしさ
音がしたが存在する以上男性が職場から
離れることは難しいし保管ジェンダーが
社会支援することも難しい
皆さんら男明日は男性を職場に縛るととも
に互換ジェンダーの社会進出を拒んでいる
から
のように女らしさが存在するでしょ
女性が社会進出することは難しいし
男性が家庭に介入することも難しい
nasa な女がしさは女性を家庭に4番
とともに
男性を家庭に家させないか
だから本当に依存社会を目指そうと思っ
たらこのらしさを壊せないといけない
こういうこそが僕がセミ椅子である本当の
理由です
男だしたと女らしさ
これらを壊せば
誰もが1人1人が自由に活躍できる離村
社会が待っていると僕は支援しています
でも乗り越えなければならない壁は
たくさんあります
しかも僕たちはそれに対する解決策をまだ
知らない
や社会に成果一定
ないんです
解決策なんてあるわけないんです
一見解決策に見えるようなもんでもその先
また別の問題が見えてくれ
逆に男なのに攻め s たみたい
一見おかしく見えることでももしかしたら
解決に一歩近づく鍵なのかもしれない
社会問題は大津安永に大きくて僕たち全員
がそれを見ても全体像なんて見えるわけ
ないんです
だから今日僕を反したのは解決策ではあり
ません
その社会という王座に飛び立つための翼を
授けたに過ぎません
だからこれだけでは解決にはつながらない
社会に成果一定
ないんです
でも間違っていることはたった一つ存在し
ます
それは行動しないということ
そこに問題があるとわかっているのにそれ
を見過ごす事だけはしちゃいけない
特にジェンダー問題に関係はない人はい
ません
さあ
行動を起こしましょう
知識なんていらない
必要なのはそこに問題があるとわかること
今日この話で問題は何か分かったはずです
つまり
もうあたは行動する準備ができている
一人じゃない
カーズ僕が仲間になります
だから一緒に
行動化しましょう
nasa
行動しないことが間違いだから